president trump is hospitalized at
walter reed medical center
after testing positive for the
coronavirus as new cases emerge among
his top advisors and allies
joining us once again from baltimore dr
tom engelsby director of the center for
health security
at johns hopkins university uh doctor i
always hesitate to ask about a specific
case
to a doctor who hasn't seen the patient
but
from your expertise knowing what we know
about the
the treatment that the president is
receiving and the fact that he's been
hospitalized
what does that tell you about his case
his condition
well chris i think the news that we
heard yesterday was largely
encouraging the fact that the president
is not requiring oxygen that
a number of lab tests were reported to
be normal and he was able to deliver
that video yesterday
but what we heard from the president's
chief of staff was concerning the the
fact that
he at least mr meadows said that his
vital signs were
concerning on friday that he was
requiring oxygen those are
those are worrisome things at least they
they suggest that the president does
have pulmonary involvement from covid if
those things are
correct and there were a number of tests
that i presume
were done at walter reed including a
chest x-ray
ct scan white blood cell count
inflammatory
inflammatory markers it would be useful
to be able to judge his risk going
forward to know what the results of
those tests were
but so far the news that we've heard has
been encouraging
well that that's encouraging to hear uh
but you anticipated where i want to take
this the president is a 74 year old man
who's
technically obese how long before we
have a sense whether
he's out of the woods and you know at
one point mark meadows was saying the
next 48 hours the doctors were saying
seven to ten days you know when are we
going to know whether he's okay and i
guess part of the question is
what is the likelihood being where he is
right now that he can participate
in a presidential debate in 11 days
it is always very difficult to make
judgments about individuals especially
unless you're really involved in the
care overall in this age
category people of the president's age
there was a large study
done by cdc in january to may time frame
that said that about a third of people
his age who were diagnosed with covid
would be hospitalized
and that there is a significant
mortality rate in that age group
now the president is receiving
extraordinary care and looks like he's
doing well but
it's certainly a serious disease for
people of his age and with
underlying condition we do know that
some people have symptoms that are mild
and recover
and do extraordinarily well in the first
week but there are others
that that in the five to ten day time
range can have a
relatively quick deterioration and
develop more severe symptoms and it's
very difficult to judge that
at this time again those additional test
results would help us make some judgment
about the likelihood of his disease
getting better
or where the potential for worsening in
terms of the debate
i i think um it's too soon to say oh go
ahead chris
i was going to ask you though because
this does get to the bigger issue
of the proper safety regulations the
rallies that the president held where
thousands of people were there uh
oftentimes
uh with no separation the vast majority
of them
not wearing masks and then as i
discussed
uh with steve cortez the president's
family and advisors
ignoring the requirement at the debate
that they wear masks as a public health
official
what do you think of that
yeah i think there is clear danger in
having
events where there are many people close
together without wearing masks for a
prolonged period of time especially
where loud voices are used that's we
know virus is spread by loud voice
more effectively so i really think large
gatherings like rallies
shouldn't be happening at this point for
any purpose during a pandemic which is
in the last few weeks actually been
getting worse
and i think when the commission sets
rules for
preventing transmission during debates
they should be followed we
people shouldn't be making their own
decisions they should be following the
rules that are established by the public
health experts who set up those debates
i want to pick up on a question i asked
mr cortez and that's the continuity of
government
because the president is in the hospital
as we say
his his prognosis is uncertain in the
course of this
your thoughts about pres vice president
pence the next in line to the presidency
going ahead with public rallies going
ahead with
this debate is that a sensible uh
action for him to take or does it raise
concerns on your part about the next
person in line to the presidency
yeah well my view at this point is that
the rest of the debates the vice
president's
vice presidential debate and if there
are presidential debates
should be virtual i think at this point
we've seen from the first debate that
there were untested unanticipated very
large risks that developed around the
debate and in the days afterwards
and in fact by public accounts it looks
like the vice president
had a meeting with the president on
tuesday a period of time where he would
be presumed to be contagious
and so in my mind it seems like the vice
president should be
in quarantine even if he is getting
tested on a normal
on a daily basis and so in any event i
don't think it
is a proper risk to take to have him
gathering with
with uh senator harris
in person and they could easily do this
debate virtually
as was done in the past for at least in
the case of kennedy and nixon i know we
did virtual debates
but for public health purposes i think
it would be safer not to have these
large gatherings at this point
uh given the risks of of the pandemic
i want to pick up on something you just
said which is that in fact the pandemic
is getting worse the president
has been sending a a a consistently
optimistic message about where we are
with covet 19
in recent days here's uh some clips from
that take a look
we're rounding the turn we're rounding
the corner of the pandemic
tremendous progress is being made and i
say it i'll say it all the time we're
rounding the corner i just want to say
that the end of the pandemic
is in sight
doctor where are we really with covet 19
at this point in this country
we are still in the middle of a
dangerous pandemic in this country
if you look at the papers this morning
and and the data you can see that
something on the order of two-thirds of
the states in the country
have had increases in coveted numbers in
the last week
and we're seeing as you said earlier in
the
40 000 range of cases every day
hospitalization rate has just begun to
tick up again
if you look at the numbers across the
country and there are places in the
country in the midwest and
particularly in wisconsin which are
having extraordinary numbers their
highest numbers yet since this pandemic
started
with places in wisconsin having trouble
accommodating all of the sick people
that are coming sick with kovid so i
think people
need to really continue to take this
very seriously
to avoid large gatherings wear masks
physically distance as they have been
over time
and hopefully in the months ahead we'll
begin to get vaccines coming online but
in the meantime it's important to take
all the precautions we've been taking
all along to prevent transmission
so i got about a minute left and and
you've answered part of it but what is
the biggest lesson
that people should take from the fact
that even the president of the united
states who was in the most secure
health bubble of anybody maybe in the
world can still get this illness what's
the lesson people should take
from that and specifically what they
should and shouldn't do
yeah i think the lesson is that this is
still the same virus the virus hasn't
changed uh
we heard earlier this week that most of
us are still susceptible to this virus
in this country only a small percentage
of us have been infected and recovered
at this point
so people should take it very seriously
we do have to find a balance
in terms of you know living our lives in
the and
trying to get the economy moving but uh
everything that people can do as
individuals in terms of masking
physically distancing avoiding large
gatherings
we should be doing that and and
hopefully in the time ahead with more
diagnostic testing and with the
coming of new therapies and vaccines the
risk will continue to go down but for
now
you need to take this virus very
seriously
dr inglesby thank you thanks for joining
us it's always good to talk with you sir